Jabba the hutt once sat upon that throne
you all accrued wealth and riches under
jabba you can again with this man boba fett
what prevents us all from killing you why speak
of conflict when cooperation can make us all rich
i am not a bounty hunter
i'm the crime lord now who is
this who enters unannounced
no damn wallow my name is boba fett
left for dead on the sands of tatooine
i intend to rule with respect in
difficult times fear is a surer bet
Welcome back everyone this will be my new
star wars book of boba fett trailer video
episode 1 is going to be dropping next week i'll
be doing videos for all the episodes so be sure
to subscribe to get them all there's going to be
seven episodes total in a ton a ton of crossovers
and cameo scenes in fact robert rodriguez
who basically directed most of these episodes
said that all the trailer footage is only
from the first episode because it gets too
spoilery after the first episode he's like there's
too many secrets too many crossovers cameo scenes
that we didn't want to reveal i think he's mostly
talking about mando grogu crossing over maybe
ahsoka also crossing over to most of the really
big mandalorian series characters will cross over
in some way so i'll address that during the video
because i know everybody's wondering like what is
grogu and luke skywalker doing right now because
there's been a small time jump since the end of
the mandalorian season two but it hasn't been that
long and they are in the middle of filming the
mandalorian season three right now that won't be
released till around the end of next year so we're
gonna get the obi-wan kenobi episodes we'll get
the star wars rogue one prequel series the andor
episodes before we get mandalorian season 3. but
just starting at the beginning of the footage
here the new trailer calls out jabba's throne
specifically they referenced it verbally in the
last trailer with one of the other local crime
lords on tatooine sees boba fett saying that
he heard he now sits on the throne of his former
employer and you may have detected a very familiar
voice when the ithorian crime lord is sitting
there recognizing boba fett like he walks into his
throne room he says who is this is walking in here
it is the voice of robert rodriguez the person
who directed all these episodes this is what his
voice actually sounds like who is this who enters
unannounced i was nine years old when first star
wars came out saw it again and again and then
all its re-releases and i was already a huge boba
fett fan before empire strikes back even came out
they show footage of him returning to jabba's
palace before the events of the mandalorian
season two maybe if this is not before the
mandalorian season two episode one when we
saw him come back for the first time at the end of
the episode and that stinger then it would have to
be like literally right after that scene because
he's wearing the exact same tuscan raider outfit
and he hasn't taken his armor back from mando
and what is happening here is that he's coming
back to jabba's palace to take his ship the slave
one back and then go after mando to get his armor
so there will be flashbacks during the series to
show you how he escaped from the sarlacc and what
happened to him immediately after like that's why
he's in this bakda tank being healed here because
it's probably right after he escapes from the
sarlacc i talked a little bit about the timeline
of that during my last big boba fett trailer
video so i'll link that in the description below
there's a big connection between the sarlacc
that he escaped from from return of the jedi
in what was happening with the krait dragon
during the mandalorian season 2 episode 1.
they have a much longer version of the suit up
montage always love the suit up montage which
reminds me of putting action figures together as
a child if it wasn't clear from the mandalorian
season 2 this is the same armor from return of
the jedi empire strikes back it's just that he's
repainted it and polished it that's why it looks
so different but you didn't notice that he did not
repair the dent in his helmet from the unfinished
clone wars episodes if you haven't seen the clip
dave filoni actually wrote the canon story for how
he got the dent in his helmet because originally
it was just a fabrication error when they were
making the movies like when they first introduced
the character there was not supposed to be a
dent in his helmet but like a lot of small star
wars details like this dave filoni used the clone
wars episodes to write a backstory for the dent
and now the canon story is that he got the
dent after a gunslinger standoff with cad bane
i know everyone's hoping for a cad bane cameo
scene during the book of boba fett he's still
alive in present day so it is possible for him
to come back but during these unfinished clone
wars episodes cad bane is fighting the younger
boba fett and shoots his helmet right off of his
head and the point of impact from his blaster
fire is what created the dent i cannot wait for
dave filoni to write a canonical backstory
for jeans guy from the mandalorian season 2
evil sith lord waiting in the shadows revenge of
the jeans they would make so much money if they
turn jeans guy into an actual action figure a fan
actually created a legit looking action figure for
jean's guy this is amazing and if it wasn't clear
the scene of him doing his suit up montage is also
inside jabba's palace but that's from later in
the timeline during the present day of the show
after the mandalorian season 2 post credits scene
where he killed bib fortuna you also noticed
the major difference here too is that he's not
wearing his helmet in a lot of the scenes because
one even though he's technically a mandalorian
genetically they kind of explained that with
his chain code from jango fett and how jango
fett used to be a mandalorian but then kind of
left their society he's not part of the crazy cult
of mandalorians that din djarin was raised by who
vowed to never take their helmets off because two
that was what the major part of bo katan kryze's
episodes were about when they first introduced her
in the series her explaining to mando who and what
real mandalorians actually were like no dude we
take our helmets off all the time you were just
part of this crazy sec that broke off of the death
watch mandalorians i'm hoping they bring back some
easter eggs for them too because the death watch
was also a group during the clone wars era that
boko tan was part of briefly but she eventually
left with her night owls group those are the other
mandalorians that you see with her with similar
armor like these are some of the night owls but
not all of them they're just like a crazy hardcore
elite group that she formed before she joined the
death watch that does kind of make you wonder if
technically mando has become one of the night owls
maybe unofficially because he still has the dark
saber and bokeh tan isn't gonna let that out of
her sight until she figures out how to get it from
him without having to kill him for it because the
whole idea is that he who wields the darksaber has
the right to rule the mandalorians like a claim to
the best gar throne to make a game of thrones
reference the iron throne the best guard throne
and that's what she really wants like she doesn't
really care about the darksaber the darksaber is
just a symbol of a right to rule my theory right
now is that she'll just use him as a figurehead
to rally more support for her cause like there
are other mandalorians who survive the purge out
there in hiding in the outer rim including
the armorer from the mandalorian season one
once they all learned that mando has the
darksaber and they've taken down moff gideon
way more of them will start crawling out of the
woodwork this new character here everybody's
wondering about is sophie thatcher you might
recognize her from yellowjackets recently but she
also starred in a space movie with pedro pascal
a couple years ago so she has had her own minor
mando crossover before this given the speeder bike
she's writing it seems like she's running from one
of the local gangs i'm assuming that she's just
a young scoundrel type character in the making
i don't know if she's playing somebody from the
lore or if she's playing a brand new character but
we should find out during episode one like i said
i believe all this footage in the trailers is from
the first episode they have another big jango fett
attack of the clones reference when he says i'm
not a bounty hunter i'm the crime lord now that's
just another wink at jango fett's simple man
speech your clones are very impressive you must be
very proud i'm just a simple man trying to make my
way in the universe like i said in my last video
this twilight is jennifer beals one of probably a
few celebrity cameos sometimes they don't always
announce their celebrity cameos though like
sometimes you don't always recognize them under
the makeup or sometimes they're just voice over
cameos like mark hamill secretly doing the voice
of EV9-D9 the droid in the most eisley cantina
mark hamill has revealed that he does this all
the time like if you go back across pretty much
all the big star wars tv shows everything they've
done he does a lot of uncredited voice over cameo
scenes then i already explained the big easter egg
here too this scene of him coming in and killing
all these other scoundrels here is an easter egg
for a deleted scene from a new hope it's when he
comes to toshi station and anchor head and meets
big's dark lighter and his other friends early in
the movie this is the exact same room the boba
fett walks into killing all these aliens and it
seems like it's pretty soon after he's come out
of the sarlacc and because we're on tatooine here
at least in episode one it sounds like a lot of
the series will take place in and around tatooine
of course there's all kinds of references to a
new hope in return of the jedi like there's a
c3po droid here there's a land speeder that looks
similar to luke skywalker's just flying right past
him there's even some pit droids from phantom
menace which we've seen a couple times during
the mandalorian series they have not said what
mando is going to be doing when he shows up on
the series but my assumption is that he's in the
middle of helping bo katan steal more weapons and
ships back from the empire and they're getting
ready to bump into grand admiral thrawn by the
time they get to the ahsoka episodes which will
take place after the mandalorian season 3. So
mando still has the darksaber grogu as far as we
know is still with luke skywalker doing his jedi
training luke skywalker has not created his jedi
academy yet though at this point in the timeline
during this point in history right after return
of the jedi he was just traveling all over the
galaxy looking for more force sensitive people to
train like grogu like that's how he found grogu
because he was specifically looking for force
sensitive people so that's why it's easier to
still have a grogu crossover because they're
still traveling all over the galaxy while he's
training him in the jedi arts but if you spotted
any other big easter eggs in this trailer footage
that i didn't talk about in the video or if
you have other questions about what's going on
with luke skywalker or grogu or the mandalorian
just write them in the comments below my full
book of boba fett episode 1 video will post next
wednesday after they release it there'll be seven
episodes total so we have a whole bunch of really
cool stuff coming up everyone click here for my
brand new doctor strange multiverse of madness
trailer video and click here for my spiderman no
way home post credits scene thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe and happy holidays!